president Trump walks away from the
North Korea summit in Vietnam the
anti-trump crowd assails him but walking
away actually was among the best
possible outcomes we will discuss why
then Nancy Pelosi hints at impeachment
who Leon Castro calls for reparations
and the Democrat first lady of Virginia
passes out cotton to black students at
the governor's mansion Michael knows and
this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
that that was not a monologue I was not
telling jokes I just read a headline at
the end which is that the first lady of
Virginia whose husband just wore black
face and tried to moonwalk during his
apology press conference was passing out
cotton to black students at the
governor's mansion that's just terrific
no way you can't really punch that up
there's no way to make that funnier a
lot to get to today we have to cover
Trump walking out of this Vietnam summit
with Kim jong-un I think it was very
good that he walked away and a lot of
people are getting this completely wrong
but first let's make some money honey
with expressvpn admit it you think that
cybercrime is something that happens to
other people oh it could never happen to
you your password is like password 1 2 3
exclamation point or something no one's
gonna guess that one you may think no
one wants your data or that hackers
can't grab your passwords or credit card
details but you are dead wrong stealing
data from unsuspecting people on public
Wi-Fi is one of the simplest and
cheapest ways for hackers to make money
you're at the airport you're whatever
you're on some public Wi-Fi people can
get into your stuff don't be stupid
protect yourself from cyber criminals
and use Express VPN expressvpn secures
and anonymizes your internet browsing by
encrypting your data and hiding your
public IP address for less than seven
bucks a month you can get the same
expressvpn protection that I have it's
rated the number one VPN service by
TechRadar comes with a 30-day money-back
guarantee I know you think I don't need
it oh I don't need it think of what you
have on your computer think of your
internet search history alright you're
probably looking at some weird stuff
like the Le wire calm you don't want
this stuff getting out protects your
online activity today find out how you
can get three months for yet expressvpn
calm slash Michael that is exp ress VPN
at gum slash michael mi CH AE L do I win
the spelling bee three months free with
a one-year package expressvpn comm slash
Michael to learn more okay president
Trump walked out of this vietnam summit
with kim jong-un other than the complete
denuclearization of the Korean Peninsula
for not very much
in the way of American concessions this
is probably the best way this could have
turned out and yet for some reason
President Trump's critics won't take yes
for an answer here's President Trump
finally describing why this summit
didn't work out they wanted the
sanctions lifted in their entirety and
we couldn't do that it was a very
productive two days but sometimes you
have to walk sometimes you have to walk
that could have been the title of
today's show sometimes you have to walk
thank goodness the president Trump knows
this because people are mocking him now
on the left and the right they're saying
I thought it was the art of the deal I
thought you could make deals President
Trump now you're walking away the
willingness to walk away is crucial to
making a deal and in fact if you are not
willing to walk away as many presidents
have not been willing to do then you
give away all of your leverage then
there's nothing left for you a lot of
people are very happy that these talks
broke down on both the left and the
right but here of course a CNN Jim
Acosta walking hairdo gloating about it
so it's strike one in Singapore he
didn't get a deal with Kim jong-un now
it's strike two in Hanoi
once again no deal to denuclearize North
Korea something that he's staked a lot
of his legacy a lot of his presidency on
and Jim and Christiana in the backdrop
of all of this is what happened back in
Washington up on Capitol Hill at the
House Oversight Committee when the
president's former fixer really just
blasted away at his former boss accusing
him of being a liar and a cheat and a
criminal basically and so on and what
was a bombshell hearing up on Capitol
Hill the president presumably will be
asked about that as well yeah and did I
tell you and Michael Cohen he said he's
racist too and he Jim you're supposed to
be covering the North Korea yeah no I
know I know but just you hear about
stormy Daniels he okay what a jerk so
president Trump walks away what I want
to know from the critics on the right
who oppose Trump walking away and from
Jim Acosta CNN and all of the people on
the left mocking him what was the
alternative what was the alternative
I guess one alternative is you never
speak to North Korea you will
tensions to continue to ramp up as they
have been since they killed otto
warmbier
and possibly deal with a land war on the
Korean Peninsula where you're risking
killing what thirty thousand a hundred
thousand civilians and Seoul I don't
know what does that mean okay maybe
you're willing to do that maybe that's
the bet you think that's the best option
or the other alternative is the Iran
nuclear deal all over again you're so
insistent on getting a deal that you'll
give away everything say well we're
already here we're at the summit
I can't possibly walk away Jim Acosta
will make fun of me so okay here we'll
take away all the sanctions North Korea
will completely open you up to the
international community completely open
you up to international trade and you
only have to get rid of like one nuclear
site okay and that's a deal that's what
that's what Barack Obama would have done
that's the Iran nuclear deal
walking away shows a position of
strength because the United States
doesn't need to engage in these summits
we don't need to give away anything we
don't need to lift sanctions on North
Korea it's not as though the sanctions
are weakening internationally it's not
as though there's some massive
international pressure to lift the
sanctions fine if they don't want to
play ball we don't need to play ball
that's the position of strength
a weaker president would have felt
pressured into coming to a deal at any
price so who's defending Trump obviously
I am the usual suspects that you would
expect from Trump world have been
defending him some people on the right
it's sort of a mixed reaction broadly on
the right he's also getting praise from
some pretty strange sources he's getting
praise from Joe Scarborough who the
president loves to mock and who Joe
Scarborough doesn't seem to feel any
love lost with President Trump and even
Joe Scarborough admits man this was
probably the right thing
MIDI say at least for me personally that
seems like the best of all circumstances
where the president continues to
communicate with the country that we
were close to war with a year ago that
most foreign policy experts gave us a
50/50 chance of having a land war in the
Korean Peninsula a year ago and
talked but didn't give away anything
which was the great fear especially
after the Cohen testimony yesterday
which we're going to get to in one
moment that's right
the issue here is sometimes you've got
to walk away and and Joe Scarborough
like a broken clock twice a day sort of
gets it right his guests right
afterwards says yep sometimes you've got
to walk away even beyond the mainstream
media
you've got Susan Rice who is a left-wing
foreign policy expert you know served
for Barack Obama
she was his flack she was the
sacrificial lamb who was sent out after
Benghazi to lie for the administration
have really tarred her career but even
Susan Rice who loves every opportunity
to criticize Trump looks at the
situation and says yeah this was the
right thing to do I want to note for
people that you wrote the other day in
the New York Times of the widespread
fear that President Trump would give
away too much be too desperate for a
deal did he make the right move in
walking away yes he did for the United
States to have agreed to lift all
sanctions in the absence of real and
complete denuclearization would have
been a tremendous mistake of course the
of course and that's not just the
opinion of left wingers like Susan Rice
that's the opinion of right-wingers like
the advisors to the president like John
Bolton like the President himself like
me this is just common sense actually
the criticism of President Trump with
regard to North Korea is that he's been
too credulous he's been too gullible oh
he'll let this strongman chubby little
dictator push him around he'll believe
him we have no reason to believe Kim
jong-un and so the fear going into this
summit was that well among people who
think the president is an idiot I'm not
among those people they said oh Kim
jong-un is gonna razzle-dazzle em he's
gonna promise him the world in exchange
for the lifting of sanctions trumps
gonna lift the sanctions and guess
what's gonna happen Kim jong-un isn't
going to denuclearize and then it's the
end of the world then you've got no
leverage whatsoever on North Korea and
then this shows that the president is
not overly credulous
is not gullible with regard to Kim
jong-un or North Korea he was looking to
achieve something but not at any cost
that's a very reasonable position to be
in what is the cost what this is what I
want to know from the critics on the
right and the left who's who or mocking
him or upset that he walked away from
this summit well what what did we lose
well we walked around with a strong man
we we elevated a strong man to meet with
the president okay
like whatever fine okay we we wanted
something which is the denuclearization
of Korea we wanted to end a conflict
that has going on now for 70 years and
one thing that we were willing to wager
for that one offering was that he could
take some pictures with President Trump
oh okay fine nothing really ventured
nothing really gained but nothing really
ventured nothing really lost it was a
good shot I'm glad that President Trump
had the political courage to take a risk
here I'll be in a small risk and then
that he had the political prudence and
judgment to walk away when it looked
like Kim gentlemen was trying to pull a
fast one now the one quote this is the
quote that people are a sailing Trump
for this is the one and this doesn't
sound good I totally agree when you
listen to it you think did he have to I
wish he didn't have to say that this is
the line that all of the mainstream
media are gonna be playing for the next
48 hours those prisons are rough they're
rough places he tells me that he didn't
know about it and I will take him at his
word talking about the killing of otto
warmbier that american student who was
killed by north korea came back and he
was brain dead he died shortly
thereafter he says well he's asked did
kim jeong-hoon know about this did Kim
jong-un do this he says look those
prisons are terrible Kim jong-un says he
didn't know about it so I guess I'll
take him at his word yeah I get it
I get it you want him what you want him
to do is go out there and say this jerk
he killed an American student he's gonna
and then like John Wayne
Trump is gonna pull a gun out of his
jacket and shoot Kim jong-un on the site
that would feel really good but that is
not reality that is not what's going to
happen but by the way for what Trump
said here factually it's probably true I
don't I don't think that Kim jong-un
ordered the killing of otto warmbier
because he had nothing to gain and a lot
to lose from it I think probably what
happened is they took in otto warmbier
they tortured him endlessly and they
tortured him a little too much and
something went wrong and then the kid
went brain-dead we still don't know
exactly why or how he went brain-dead
why or how his is torture and his
incarceration killed him and then I
think the North Korean regime was
terrified I mean I think they they
really wanted to rough him up and use
him as leverage a guy who's dead or
dying is not much leverage then really
extract any concessions from it so just
as a technical matter maybe he's right
but what people are really criticizing
him for is that he didn't just assail
Kim Jong on for the North Korean killing
of otto warmbier now kim jongmin says i
didn't know yeah maybe he didn't I don't
think he ordered the killing sure maybe
he didn't know maybe some guard took it
too far yeah okay is that now is that
awful yes is that does that make an
American's blood boil yes does it make
us want to go to war yes here is where
you see that Donald Trump is the exact
opposite of Barack Obama will explain
how in a minute but first speaking of
protection we the people holsters got to
make some money they offer custom-made
holsters all produced in the USA they
designed their unholsters in-house means
they don't use any third-party molds for
their holsters instead they design every
unique mold in Las Vegas to best fit
each and every firearm perfectly they
even have their own 3d design team who
measures every micro millimeter of their
guns to ensure the perfect fit you can
easily adjust both the can't and ride of
your holster so that will fit
comfortably and securely at all times
every holster has adjustable retention
it's signaled with a click sound custom
printed designs in-house thin blue line
camo Constitution the American flag new
designs coming out all the time
we the people holsters start at just 37
dollars a piece so I would
say look don't cheap out you know make
sure you get a really quality holster
like we the people holsters luckily you
can have both because they're very
inexpensive as well they start at 37
apiece every holster comes with a
lifetime guarantee every holster ships
free if it's not a perfect fit send it
back for a refund
right now my listeners can go to We the
People holsters comm slash Knowles pay
no wles enter promo code Knowles kenda
wles at checkout get 10 bucks off your
first holster so that's as low as 37
dollars and shipping is free and you get
an additional ten bucks off using my
promo code again We the People holsters
comm slash Knowles cane or wles promo
code Knowles at checkout for $10 off
this controversy over president Trump's
answer to the question about otto
warmbier he says well kim jonghwan says
he didn't know i guess i'll take him at
his word even though those prisons are
really tough those prisons are really
tough so maybe that explains it he's
being assailed on both sides for that
what this shows is that Trump is the
opposite of Obama Barack Obama talked
real tough oh he said the prettiest
words didn't he and then he gave away
the forum that was the series all red
lines were talking tough on the mullahs
were and then take anything you want
flying airplanes full of American cash
to drop off with the Iranian mullahs
thanking Iran for taking our sailors
hostage get to anything to get those
sailors back any I don't know there's no
giveaway everything all concessions
concessions to Syria concessions to
everybody but he would talk tough he'd
give good speeches wouldn't he and
President Trump doesn't talk tough on
kim jongmin he talks like he's
negotiating he says well Kim Jong un
he's a smart guy yeah he's a smart smart
guy yeah well he says he didn't know
about his States killing of otto
warmbier I guess I'll take him at his
word ok so he he talks really nice he
talks in a flattering way but then he
doesn't give away anything which of
those two guys do you want to lead your
country the one who tells you every
pretty little thing you want to hear and
then sells it sells out your country
from underneath you or the guy who's
willing to make rhetorical concessions
but never make any hard concessions any
tangible concessions obviously you want
the latter this room walking away
reminds me of Reykjavik it reminds me of
Ronald Reagan 1986 Reagan is there with
Gorbachev they're talking about
denuclearization at one point they're
talking about complete denuclearization
and these talks are going exceedingly
well between the the US and the Soviet
Union and then at the very end Gorbachev
says ok and you've got to get rid of the
Strategic Defense Initiative this was
the initiative that was criticized by
Reagan's detractors as Star Wars you're
gonna be able to shoot missiles out of
the sky although you know this brand-new
radical technology technology that then
at the time we didn't even have and
Reagan said how dare you how could you
do this and he walked right out furious
walked right out of the summit listen to
how Trump's detractors are talking about
this summit and wonder how would they've
talked about Reykjavik say oh well they
should have known ahead of time what the
terms were what a complete failure of
Trump's negotiating what a complete
failure of planning what a complete
failure of our credulity with regard to
North Korea oh how embarrassing
we legitimized this slave master tyrant
by appearing with him as an American
president oh what a total catastrophe
what dunces in the White House that's
what they're saying about president from
some summit with Kim jong-un which of
those lines could you not apply to
Reagan at Reykjavik you could apply all
of the same lines and what happened as a
result of Reykjavik one year later we
got a nuclear treaty with the Soviet
Union the Reykjavik was 86 we got a
treaty in 87 am I saying that's what's
gonna happen in North Korea no no I'm
I'm hopeful but I'm not optimistic I
there's a distinction there I'm I hope
that it works out I think it's possible
that it will work out but Kim jong-un is
no Mikhail Gorbachev Donald Trump is no
Ronald Reagan these are different times
different
Krim stanzas different relationship but
the summit itself the principle itself
of walking out of a summit without a
deal that's exactly the same 1986 2019
and the arguments for walking away are
way stronger than the arguments for
giving away the form this is short of
the complete denuclearization of North
Korea for no American concession this is
the best outcome we possibly could have
gotten from President Trump here so I
guess nothing ventured nothing gained
good job president Trump and not selling
out the country your predecessors might
have done that wish we could have gotten
a deal yeah because my feeling this is
my feeling on all of the news this week
Michael Cohen bombshell bombshell hey
the North Korean summit walks away
pretty good okay fine whatever now on
the other side of the aisle Nancy Pelosi
is outlining her priorities this this
actually has not really been covered by
any major news outlets or it's been it's
been very under covered Nancy Pelosi
speaking at Howard University outlines
the Democrats plan for the new Congress
now that they have control of the House
of Representatives and if it really
reveals that Nancy Pelosi is a very
masterful political manipulator and she
lists her top nine and then she says
number 10 whew that's gonna be a little
surprise who you're gonna have to be
ready for that here she is we have one
through ten for the people that one is
clean up government two was the
infrastructure bill Brees prescription
drugs that lower the cost of resolution
four is the Voting Rights Act five is
the Equality Act which is to end
discrimination against the LGBTQ
community six is the DREAM Act to
protect our dreamers 7 is Paycheck
there's equal pay for equal work
building on President Obama
eight is today HR eight House Resolution
eight bipartisan background checks nine
will be a climate bill and then we have
ten reserved for something special that
will you have to be ready you know you
have to be ten reserved for something
special you have to be ready okay people
are wondering what could she be talking
about because if you listen to the first
nine she basically covers all the bases
all the leftist bases the one policy
that she's missing within there he is
Medicare for all this socialist totally
socialist medicine but I don't think
that's missing I don't think that's what
she's referring to because she does talk
about lowering prescription drug prices
so she were gonna push for Medicare for
all socialist medicine but she would
just include it in there she wouldn't be
it would be redundant for her to have
both of those the other thing that that
you notice about those first nine is
they're actually all plausible what
Nancy Pelosi is signaling is she doesn't
doesn't just want to obstruct she
doesn't just want to slow down Trump's
agenda she doesn't just want to pass or
hold a lot of meaningless votes that
will certainly get stopped in the Senate
certainly get vetoed it seems that she's
trying to work with the president maybe
she's learned something from the last
couple years she wants an infrastructure
bill Trump could get behind that she
wants a clean up government bill yeah
Trump could probably get behind that she
wants an LGBTQ equality act you think
that's a little further left
don't forget President Trump touted
himself is the most Pro LGBT Republican
presidential nominee in history
you've got equal pay for equal work this
kind of sounds like it makes sense it
sounds like a feel-good bill this
pandering to women bill it's based on
the premise that women only get 75 cents
for every dollar that a man makes it's
not true at all but you could see some
Senate Republicans maybe liking this
maybe Susan Collins these kind of lefty
Republicans Susan Collins likes and
maybe Lisa Murkowski likes it maybe
Ivanka Trump in the White House who
made quite a point of talking about
women's issues and really buying the
left-wing premises on a lot of those
issues maybe she like okay maybe that
kind of works after lowering
prescription drug prices you could see
President Trump getting behind that
would play to his base okay so it's all
basically plausible Medicare for all is
not plausible socialist medicine that is
it that is not a winner president Trump
ran in no small part on overturning
Obamacare that's that's not gonna be it
what she's obviously implying is
impeachment that's the only thing she
could be she says we're reserving number
ten for something special well all of is
is all of that legislation that she just
named not special the climate bill LGBT
women's bill this bill that bill yeah
what she's saying is we're reserving it
for something that's more special
ordinary legislation being passed by
Congress that's not special
that's just what Congress does
impeachment is special only Congress can
do that it's a rare occurrence that that
happens that's something special and
then she says we've just got to be ready
well you don't have to be ready for all
those other bills no because all of that
legislation they can go in that's that's
their agenda for the new Congress
impeachment will hinge on the Moller
report impeachment will hinge on all of
the testimony that they're they're gonna
call Michael Cohen they're gonna call
Eric Trump they're gonna call Don jr.
they're gonna call all these people to
testify it's gonna hinge on the endless
investigations that Adam Schiff is
launching that's why you've got to be
ready and why doesn't she name it
she doesn't name it because right now
impeachment is a loser issue the
majority of Americans by a significant
more margin
do not want president Trump impeached
Nancy Pelosi has previously suggested
that she wouldn't impeach Trump she
learned the lesson of Bill Clinton she
saw what happened when you overreach
when you try to impeach a president
who's basically popular whose policies
are basically popular doesn't look good
doesn't doesn't benefit the the in the
90s didn't benefit the Republicans in
the House and she's worried it won't
benefit the Democrats in the house now
in 2019 so why does she bring it up at
all well because
her agenda is plausible and she's
signaling to Donald Trump I am going to
not play as an obstructionist I'm gonna
play as someone trying to work with you
and if you do not work with me if you do
not come to the table then I've got
impeachment in my pocket
what she's signaling is she's
politically smart we all know this she's
been in power a very long time there was
a little threat to her power when the
Democrats retook the Congress some
threats some people said they were gonna
run for house leadership against her
what did Nancy say she said come on in
the water is warm
chomp chomp chomp she's a shark she's
saying you know I'm not going to impeach
you yet I'm not going to talk about it
yet because it's unpopular right now but
the minute I get the opportunity ooh boy
that's gonna be real special I guess
we'll just have to wait Democratic
presidential candidates have other
policy priorities including reparations
for slavery we'll get to that in one
second then of course we have the
mailbag coming up but first I've got a
second bite of Facebook in youtube if
you're on facebook and youtube go to
daily wire.com it is ten bucks a month
$100 for an annual membership you get me
at the end reclaim ensure you get the
Ben Shapiro show you get them out well
sure you get to ask questions in the
mailbag coming up you get to ask
questions backstage we're doing a lot of
those these days you get another Kingdom
you get this you get mmm that's you get
the the profound sadness of Nancy Pelosi
that she cannot yet impeach the
president and it tastes very good a
little no son it's more of a vintage
we'll put it that way it's been around
Congress a very long time but you've got
those leftist ears right now make sure
you get the tumbler immediately because
as the Cohen testimony falls apart as
president Trump doesn't give away the
farm to North Korea you are going to
need it lest you drown come back and
we'll be right back in just one minute
whoo Leon Castro is running his campaign
not unlawful Policy Priorities but on
reparations for slavery that ended over
150 years ago
here is Castro on MSNBC of course giving
out his new brand-new policy proposal I
have long believed that this country
should resolve its original sin of
slavery and that one of the ways we
should consider doing that is through
reparations for people who are the
descendants of slaves it is interesting
to me that under our Constitution and
otherwise that we compensate people if
we take their property shouldn't we
compensate people if they were property
sanctioned by the state yes perhaps you
should give something to those people
who were property those people who were
property have been dead for a hundred
years at least right they've all been
dead for a hundred years of course so
what is the what is he doing Oh Leon
Castro is talking about reparations
because he's nobody in a crowded field
of people who were mediocre or slightly
better than mediocre and he's far less
than mediocre so he has to stand out it
shows you that the Democrats are going
to be running to the left now if he felt
that the space if he felt the way that
he could make his mark in the primary
was to moderate a little bit against the
green new deal against outlawing planes
trains and automobiles against knocking
down every building in the country if he
felt it was too moderate he would
moderate he's another pilot he's a
politician that's all he is
he's not some grand visionary who's a
real conviction politician he's a guy
who wants to be President he was the HUD
secretary that's his great qualification
he sees reparations for slavery as the
best path forward he's probably right
gets him on MSNBC gets him on this show
get some a little bit more attention in
in a field that doesn't care about
giving him attention and it's worth
pointing out he's it's not that he's
more radical than his fellow Democrats
it's not that he's more radical than
Nancy Pelosi
he's just reckless he's just playing
this game where he has got to get
attention he has got to go where the
base is and this is where the bases look
if Nancy Pelosi felt that she could
survive politically as Speaker of the
House by talking about the sort of stuff
she'd be talking about it to the whole
party is move very left-wing but some
people are a little more honest than
others and you're gonna see that honesty
tick up during the entire campaign
speaking of before we get to the the
mailbag today I just have to bring up
this story
speaking of honesty no Democrats have
ever been more honest than the governor
and the first lady of Virginia governor
Northam you'll remember came out and
said that he was perfectly fine killing
babies after they had been born sitting
on the doctors table this is the logical
conclusion of the Democrats abortion
stance and ecomo was fairly honest about
this other Democrats who used to say
that they supported safe legal and rare
abortion were being dishonest now
they're honest when they talk about
their sanctimonious holier-than-thou
stance on race you have to remind
Democrats you're the party of the KKK
you're the party of slavery you are the
party of the soft bigotry of low
expectations and what is relevant with
him do he wear his black face in what is
now very famous photograph he tries to
moonwalk during a an apology press
conference about that his wife's oh
don't don't moonwalk that's not a good
look don't do a Michael Jackson
impression at a blackface apology
conference and then what comes out today
the first lady passed out cotton to
black students in the governor's mansion
okay I mean great thank you thank you
for being honest
now the reason I bring this up I don't
look maybe maybe she was bringing them
around and saying look here they used to
pick cotton right here at our estate
here you go fine that's a reasonable
read that's a charitable read of what
she was doing I don't know that she's
some vicious racist maybe she is but I'm
not willing to conclude that what I want
to ask is what would happen if all of
the
had occurred to a Republican governor
well we know CNN initially reported that
Ralph Northam is a Republican they
switched his political party they were
so embarrassed now they don't mention
his political party at all and what
really strikes me about this it's just
the media reaction to it how would they
have given the GOP a charitable read of
this they've said look maybe it wasn't
no they would have run them out of town
on a rail but this is how they treat the
Virginia first lady you know guys when I
saw this story it made me kind of sad
because I just think she's just giving a
tour she's just trying to put history in
context and it all depends on how she
delivered it I wasn't there but if she
said can you imagine being this person
or can you imagine a little black child
what this was like I don't believe that
that was her intention I was there at
the mansion and met them both she was
very lovely she was even talking about
the history of the of the house yeah I
always called you last night when I saw
this I do think it's important and I
applaud the first lady for actually
saying look this is where slaves worked
here in the governor's mansion in the
past and put things in context yes and
actually picking cotton was extremely
back-breaking work and I think that's
the point again we weren't there but I
can't imagine that she would have been
that insensitive to this young person
who was there it made me say I think we
were so quick to jump on things now
everybody's super and hypersensitive
when it comes to racial issues in
particular it does appear to have been
well intentioned I think so too
yeah come on obviously it was no I think
it was even better intention than you do
no I think it was better intentioned
no of course we have to we're so quick
to jump on people we're some mark
meadows as a racist
we're so no no we're just so quick to
jump on Donald Trump as Hitler and we
just need to stop being so quick to jump
on people Donald Trump is a white
supremacist been that that's what they
are I'm actually the point there is a
broader point to take away from this
that all of us could learn which is that
it is a fact of human nature that we
judge others by their actions and would
judge ourselves by our intentions we
judge others when we don't like them we
judge them by their worst possible read
of what they did and we always judge
ourselves by the best possible read of
we wanted to do yeah that's a great
point to take away but that how
oblivious not to apply it to themselves
they just yesterday we're calling the
whole House GOP racist because they read
the testimony of a black Trump employee
who said he's not racist machinae to
leave the Democrat congresswoman said
that Republicans were racist for using a
black woman as a prop then the
Republicans said you just called a black
woman a prop she's not a prop she had
testimony relevant testimony that double
standard is amazing if they if they
could listen to their own point and
actually take it it would be a good
point but of course they can't all right
let's get to the mailbag running late as
usual but I want to get through as many
as we can first question from Andrew
hello I was wondering how you feel about
the belief that God views all sin
equally thank you Andrew I don't agree
with it because it isn't true you can
look at James 2:10 James 2:10 says quote
for whoever keeps the whole law but
fails in one point has become guilty of
all of it this is the line usually by
people who say god views all sin equally
all sin is exactly to say God views all
sin equally is to say that all sin is
equal God doesn't view something
incorrectly God is the truth and so if
God views it some way that is the way
that it is so the question is is all sin
equal is stealing a pack of gum from the
store the same thing as killing a
pregnant woman and beheading her and
what are you know doing all sorts of
horrific things are those exactly equal
sins the answer of course is no we know
this intuitively we know this
philosophically and we know this from
Scripture in first John 5:17 it says
quote all wrongdoing is sin but there is
sin which is not mortal so it's a it's
just right there in scripture that says
yes all wrongdoing is sin but not all
sins are created equal not all sins are
equal some sin is mortal and some sin is
venial this is a distinction that has
been held most notably by the Catholic
Church but I
other other denominations as well st.
Paul tells Christians in Rome to keep
the faith quote otherwise you too will
be cut off and then we know that we all
stumble in many ways also from Scripture
what do we make how do we make sensible
we all stumble in many ways you should
keep the faith otherwise you too will be
cut off so there were some some ways in
which we stumble that will cut us off in
some ways that won't all wrongdoing is
sin but there is a sin which is not
mortal so how is it then also the case
that whoever keeps the whole law but
fails in one point has become guilty of
all of them because you have violated
the law think of the law as a leftist
here's tumblr now this is not a perfect
analogy because the leftist here's
tumblr is indestructible so you can't
possibly break it but let's say let's
say in some crazy world I were drinking
out of my tumblr and I broke off just
the little cap of the tumbler just came
off you know just this little slider
right here okay I broke the tumbler even
though I only broke that little bit
I broke the tumbler the tumbler is the
law if you break a little piece of the
law you have broken the law certainly
that's true this does not mean that all
sin is equal this is why the New
Testament goes to great lengths in many
places to explain why not all sin is
equal in explicit terms this is why our
Lord this is why Christ in the Gospels
describes different gradations of
punishment in Luke and Matthew there are
different gradations of punishment
because sins are not all all equal this
is this is another example this happens
quite a lot I get this in the mailbag
sometimes they say Michael what about
this one line of Scripture taken
completely out of context doesn't this
invalidate your entire theology say no
because of context because you have to
read it in context you have to know when
you when you look at the scripture
without an interpretive scheme without
context without knowing what the words
mean without understanding how some
words can refer to one thing and and and
that can modify another statement that
has elaborated on that
when you just look at that one line it
is like looking into a deep dark well
and seeing only your reflection on the
surface of the water all shallows are
clear
next question from Jonathan hello back
in the day did you ever get yourself in
a situation in which you go and try to
ask a girl out on a date or try to give
her a rose but then she tells you she
has a boyfriend oh yeah you I usually
would wait until the boyfriend was out
of town before I would go do that but I
guess yeah sometimes I get my timing a
little wrong yes
yeah that's happened that's too bit
sometimes it's that isn't true sometimes
the girl is just trying to let you down
gently in which case maybe you know you
should be grateful that she was so
cordial or you know you can you can try
to you know try to be a little more
charming possibly but there is a there
is a real code here man
you shouldn't steal a guy's girl at
least if it's a friend of yours
I guess if he's a real jerk you know
open season do what you got to do but
but yeah that happens you know it's just
that's the way it is this is for Alyssa
miss if you're if a girl is so beautiful
and lovely that she's got your attention
she's probably got the attention of a
lot of other guys too and you got a you
got to go in there and win her over from
Elias Knowles if you were on your
deathbed and you had to hear one last
song before you fade out what would it
be
thanks love the show Elias this is a
very tough question assuming I didn't
have a whole lot of time left I would
probably pick a song from the 1920s
called trees which was based on a poem
written by Joyce Kilmer and the the poem
is some I think that I shall never see a
poem as lovely as a tree does something
something something something goes on
going on
poems are made by fools like me but only
God can make a tree and it's a lovely
simple little poem and the music is just
this lovely music of very 1920s and nice
and sort of the last gasp of elevated
music I'd probably do that one or
there's
another song that I love by the Mills
Brothers called smoke rings and where do
they go these smoke rings I blow each
night where do they go these circles are
blue and white and it's a song about
watching the these gasps watching your
breath watching the smoke rings fade
away into the sky of blue and wondering
what that means is talking about the
ephemeral nature of this world and
wondering about the next probably those
two I think that songs from the 20s - or
20s or 30s
next question from Joshua hey Michael I
asked Ben the same question do you think
socialism's rise in popularity is the
FreeMarkets Way of telling us that
capitalism isn't working for a lot of
Americans thanks Michael keep up the
great work Josh no I think it's the Way
of telling us that our education system
isn't working for a lot of Americans
because of course there are legitimate
criticisms of free markets that are
divorced from any sense of morality or
virtue or religiosity plenty of good
criticisms but those aren't the
criticisms that we're really seeing what
we're seeing are is just simply
ignorance blithe ignorance ocasion
Cortez the spokesman for socialism said
that the the reason that the
unemployment rate is low is because
people have two jobs that's just not how
the unemployment rate works
okay SEO Cortes is a sailing tax
incentives to bring jobs to a city
because she thinks that they're just
spending the money three billion dollars
three billion dollars is just sitting
around in a pile somewhere she doesn't
understand what a tax incentive is this
is not a failure of markets this is a
failure of education now I I don't think
that's the same reason why some people
are questioning certain trade deals
that's very different the the move of
especially Millennials toward socialism
that is born out of ignorance historical
and economic ignorance the move of some
people toward questioning open borders
on questions of migration or trade
toward questioning maybe why we should
protect certain industries if our
trading partners are also protecting
industries if we're looking at certain
trade protections because our trading
partners are stealing our intellectual
property and violating WTO treaties
World Trade Organization treaties and
illegally subsidizing their aluminum and
if you haven't caught on I'm talking
about China that I think it is much more
legitimate that's not coming out of an
ignorance that's coming out of the
failures of an economic regime that is
not perfectly free markets obviously
it's not perfectly free markets because
the the main criticism is that our
trading partners are not playing by the
rules
that's totally legitimate but those are
completely different questions and
coincidentally we're not coincidentally
you're seeing this ignorant run toward
socialism on the left and you're seeing
a very wise and serious questioning of
our trade policy's on the right from
alone would you be anti-abortion for
transwomen alone you know this is going
to be a rare example of me being
conciliatory reaching across the aisle
finding middle ground I think we should
get rid of all abortion for people with
uterus but for people who don't have
uterus I would be willing to say they
can have all the abortions they want
they can have tote and no restrictions
whatsoever no parental consent I'm
actually willing to have the federal
government subsidize all abortions for
people who don't have uteruses don't say
I'm not willing to make a deal don't say
I'm not willing to compromise from Devon
hi Michael do you think the US should
make English the official language of
the country should it be left in the
states I always enjoy listening thanks
Devon yes we should make it the official
language of the country why because
there's very little that unifies us
anymore as a country because a radical
individualist atomistic philosophy is
taken hold we don't have much of a
common culture we don't have a common
religion we don't have common cultural
experiences basically the last thing we
have is the language and the left wants
to get rid of that too and also because
language shapes our consciousness
language shapes how we think language is
is the stuff of our consciousness its
languages are different and that's why
cultures are different it's why they
think differently it's why they
view the world differently it's why
Eskimos have 5500 words for snow I don't
think that's actually true but the
principle actually is is one is what
they're alluding to here which is that
certain languages emphasize certain
things certain ways of viewing the world
and that we should have a unified
language last question from Matthew
hello all-knowing Knowles I'm from Long
Island I'm one of the only conservatives
in my group of friends my friends and I
have had relatively the same upbringing
schooling environmental stimuli but
they're leftists and I'm not I know this
is multifactorial but what is your take
on why people lean left or right
politically kind regards Matt I think
there is a little bit of a disposition
here there is such a thing as a
conservative disposition but people who
have a conservative disposition can be
politically left-wing this is sort of
the the elites they left the limousine
liberal is sort of conservative in their
disposition they get married they invest
their money they're very wise in their
own personal conduct but they preach
these radical politics so there is a
little dispositional thing I don't
really think it affects people's
political views very much being a
contrarian helps because you're always
willing to consider other ideas and I do
think the only other dispositional
aspect is openness or is a humility are
you humble enough to think maybe I don't
know everything about the world maybe
someone else has something that I can
learn and when you grow up in a
left-wing place like you and I did in
New York if you're if you have any
intellectual humility and if you have
any openness then you're naturally going
to be left-wing because that's just
everyone around you is left-wing but if
you're a little humble if you're a
little curious if you're open to new
ideas then you will be convinced by
conservative arguments because they're
better than leftist arguments and if
your friends are not intellectually
curious or have any humility or anything
then they're not going to be I think
that's the big difference okay that's
our show we have a lot more to get to
but sad come back next week we'll see
you all on Monday in the meantime I'm
Michael Knowles this is Michael Nolan
show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa of era production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19